justice ruth bader ginsburg was a
consistent liberal voice on the supreme
court for
27 years so if her replacement is a
conservative
as expected that it will be that could
reshape the court for a generation to
come
her death leaves a court with three
liberal leaning members and five others
who lean conservative
chip reed is at the supreme court he was
once little known fact
a student of justice ginsburgs at
columbia law school what
i just heard that just now jeffrey so
before we go
the question i have for you is what are
the issues that are at stake at the high
court but first
i want to know about you number one i
had no idea you went to law school that
you were practicing lawyer
what was she like in class and why are
you reporting and not being a lawyer
we're very glad you're here
more fun than being a lawyer so i did
six years of practicing law that was
plenty
but in class ruth vader ginsburg was
amazing it was a small seminar class
spring of 1980 that's how long ago it
was right before she went to the u.s
court of appeals
she was so soft-spoken but everybody was
hanging
on every word making sure they didn't
miss anything
and to answer your other question what's
at stake here will a huge array
of enormously important issues starting
with health care soon after election the
election day the court is expected to
decide whether or not the affordable
care
act individual mandate is constitutional
if overturned it could leave millions
without health insurance then there's
reproductive rights
since roe v wade was decided in 1973
abortion rights opponents
have been challenging that decision in
june in a 5-4
ruling the court struck down a louisiana
law that could have left the state with
one abortion clinic
other cases that have been decided by
five to four margins have had profound
consequences
for climate change and immigration for
example in 2007 the court decided
the epa has the authority to regulate
greenhouse gases
and in june the court stopped the trump
administration
from dismantling the program that
protects so-called dreamers
from being deported and then of course
there is the presidential election
if the results of that election are
challenged as so many people expect
just might happen the supreme court
might have the final say
just like they did back in 2000 and tony
if you hear a lot of noise there are
some very noisy anti-trump protesters
over here who are very angry about the
possibility that they would confirm
somebody
before election day tony no slow days in
washington dc especially not between now
and election day chip thank you very
much
joining us now are university of
baltimore school of law professor kim
whaley and george washington university
law professor jonathan turley good
morning to you both
uh for more depth here on on the loss of
justice ginsburg and what it means now
for the court jonathan i want to go to
you first
this means there are going to be eight
justices for these upcoming cases in the
fall session
what could that mean for the cases
themselves how will it impact
the votes well there's no true draws on
the supreme court
if there is a tie four to four the case
below
prevails so whoever prevailed with that
case prevails again with a tie
the court usually does not rehear many
cases with kennedy
they reheard for thomas i think they
reheard uh
two or three same thing with gorsuch
kavanaugh they were heard
one so most of the time they don't
re-hear cases
it's these five-four decisions or if
they have a four-four split
they'll consider that it's not a lot of
cases but they have done it before
what's most common is they'll try to eke
out a narrower decision
to avoid these four four splits all
right kim
justice ginsburg was known as a reliably
liberal leaning vote
on the court without her vote how will
that change the dynamic between liberal
conservative and how will particular
cases potentially
be decided differently in her absence
well we've seen just the chief justice
roberts go
to the center really since justice
kennedy retired from the court so when
we have
uh four justices that are reliably
conservative on one side four justices
reliably progressive on the other and
justice the chief justice who's a
conservative
sort of sometimes nodding towards the
liberal side you take justice ginsburg
out of that lineup and then we have
a solid solidly six-person conservative
court and so we will i think presumably
for many many
years um given that it looks like
there'll be a younger person probably
appointed if it goes through with donald
trump
for for generations we will see a
solidly a conservative court
on issues of social justice and
essentially when there's a question on
how to read the ambiguity in a
constitute in the constitution
someone like justice ginsburg would
defer to
the individual rights concerns of
individual citizens a more conservative
court
might look more towards the the rights
of
entities like corporations for example a
lot of that the breakdown
kind of comes down to that on legal
issues so i've got one final question i
want to put to both of you
jonathan you go first and then kim
you'll have the final word and that is
about the issue
before every american right now the
election if that election is
challenged as we hear it might be both
republicans and democrats are hiring
lawyers
for that eventuality how could
ginsburg's absence in this 4-4
lock at the court affect the election
outcome jonathan
it could be significant notably uh
justice ginsburg herself
said that a president has every right to
appoint someone
uh in his final year and justice
sotomayor said that she hoped they would
hurry to get back to a nine
court judge court a night justice court
and this could be a serious problem if
we have a 4-4
split there's likely to be challenges
here
and that is an argument that the trump
administration is likely to use that
they need a full panoply of
justices going into what may be the most
important decisions in an election
in the history of the court kim could
this nominee from president trump in
effect deliver republicans the election
in a challenged
vote in 2020 well
it's really hard to imagine they're
going to be able to confirm someone in
45 days it takes on average about 69
days
but yes i mean justice ginsburg was a
strong advocate
for voting rights the conservatives on
the court are not but i would say
frankly if we can see
more things stay in the legislatures and
not go to the supreme court
maybe even because there's a 4-4 split
that would be good for the american
people because when the court decides
something is a matter of the
constitution
it's essentially like amending the
constitution and these are five
people on a dime court uh nine justice
court that that are not elected and i
think that's really important for
americans to remember
it's better to keep things in we the
people in the ballot box
than than send things to the united
states supreme court all right kim
whaley jonathan turley we'll have to
have you both back on when we talk about
the next
topic on everyone's mind which is
potentially expanding the court which
could be very interesting thank you both
for now